je suis d'accord avec le fait qu'ils
aient un sentiment d'insécurité qu'elle
en sécurité pour autant je pense qu'il
faut pas négliger un ressenti si un
ressenti dans sécurité il faut le
traiter nos sur la question c'est
comment on traite madame va plutôt
pensez vous des styles me trompe que
délinquance immigration en réalité j'ai
réagi lundi vous l'avez dit merci
puisque nommé chaleur et rouge sang mais
parce qu'on sait que ça va venir mais
moi je l'expliqué et moi je t'explique
autrement moi je vois plutôt
c'est triste mais dans des territoires
justement où il ya un réel sentiment
d'insécurité et ben des élus en galère
parce que ces sujets n'est rarement dans
ces territoires là où on se bat pour
avoir des effectifs où l'on se bat pour
avoir l'ouverture de commissariats on
l'a vu à marseille on l'a vu dans 93 on
le voit dans 80 ans d'angoua dans plein
de territoire la réalité c'est que
aujourd'hui ce sentiment d'insécurité
il est réel on va pas lui est bon je ne
nie pas et je ne dis pas qui a pas
d'agression et je vois là le problème
c'est que
contrairement les prêts c'est que c'est
de ma faute c'est maintenant c'est ça
c'est de ma faute c'est moi qui alimente
le sentiment
à la cage inviolée le faire minière
blanche neige au pays des marnaudes
coup sur la tête mal à cacher sa misère
blattmann qui en augmente à la réunion
calmez-vous mal à discuter avec mon nom
c'est pas le cas mais les victimes ne
vais pas me
à côté des problèmes ces papas lila
parole
des auteurs et maxime alors laissez vous
plaît verrai quand ce sera votre tour
raquel garrido faudra consoeurs elle
répondu oui oui moi je pense que on est
dans un pays dangereux en est en danger
pour plein de raisons plein de raisons
nous les femmes on est en danger dans
dans nos foyers avec nos conjoints
on est en dans nos enfants les enfants
sont en danger ils sont victimes les
enfants placés sont victimes
l'actualité récente grave ces dangers là
je le disais il ya quinze jours le
nombre de tentatives de suicide chez les
jeunes a été multiplié par 4 c'est une
étude de l'hôpital debré ça c'est un
type de danger qui est là et qui
requiert une action des pouvoirs publics
que pour l'instant on ne voit pas les
associations féministes moins d'un
milliard d'euros il ya un bouleversement
culturel à faire par rapport au
patriarcat le fait que les hommes
pensent que les femmes sont leurs objets
qu'elle les méprise et c est ça nous met
en danger il ya d'autres dangers qui
sont crapuleux vous vous le disiez
parfaitement confrères l'appât du gain
voilà l'appât du gain va faire que dans
dans un quartier les trafiquants
défendre leur bifteck avec des
kalachnikovs que mais l'appât du gain ça
va aussi plus loin ça va dans
l'entreprise où ils font pas attention
aux mesures de sécurité dans les zones
ne sont pas en mourir les addictions le
krach en voyant dont on parle est là
mais mais mais la mise en danger vous
savez c'est des centaines de personnes
qui meurent au travail chaque année on
est tué par notre travail il ya plein de
choses mais là la pollution c'est aussi
une entente
est là comment on parle du danger
s'ils sont engagés à écrire alors que
j'allais mourir car lorsque aussi le
paramètre jamais changé c'est l'accès à
la justice et à la brousse parce que je
suis obligé en tant qu ancien policier
de dénoncer gérer le démantèlement
organisé du service public depuis de ces
dernières décennies je veux dire
aujourd'hui moi j'étais au commissariat
de drancy ce matin c'est allah ou était
monsieur zemmour dont dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure j'étais ce matin j'étais
au commissariat il y avait 10 personnes
qui attendaient de pouvoir déposer
plainte il n'y avait qu'une seule
personne qui est en mesure de pouvoir de
relever les pins donc c'est à dire
plusieurs heures d'attentes ya personne
pour accueillir les gens parce qu' il
manque deux agents administratifs au
commissariat de drancy donc moi j'aurais
bien aimé qu'on montre cette réalité
plutôt d'expliquer pourquoi les chiffres
baissent du coup parce que la personne
doit prendre les plaintes personnes
armées s'est super
bien mais c'est un peu ça qu'on déduit
moi
je dis que c'est qu'on est en train de
démanteler les services publics accès à
la justice et plus donc toutes les
places ne sont pas reçus à que les
athlètes la sécurité les interventions
police secours etc sont moins nombreuses
et qu'on est moins en sécurité parce
qu'il ya moins de police et moins
d'effectuer son vélo je te laisse
sécher passé qui s'est produite
il ya plus de policiers par habitant et
par le mètre carré à neuilly que chez
moi par exemple moi j'aime à bagnolet on
demande un peu un commissariat de fait
l'exercice depuis des années et on ne
l'a pas lesquels dussart ya des lilas et
des tutelles et les policiers quel
rapport avec la avec le sujet labonté
ville en sécurité là ça les intéresse
mais ne songe à quoi l'accès à nos
officiers de police judiciaire
la nasa lui là c'est la loire et globale
de l'insécurité on parle pas quartier
par quartier si on parle de l'arrivée
comment donc je parle un peu de ce que
je veux aussi main en mettant les gens
ont aimé ou les gens présents avec
saveur marquée